weinert da guckt man gehässig der es auf
der seite stehen aber nicht nur von ihm
ja oder ja herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine damen und herren zu einem gewissen
special video auf seinem kanal was ich
so noch nie hochgeladen habe und ich hab
ich hab allgemein den kurs gestützt
ich glaube ich einmal aber wir haben es
uns hier drinnen ja ein bisschen
gemütlich gewarnt da traut ihr euch dass
ihr trotz das wirklich nicht so dass die
flamme zugehen aber man weiß ja wer der
harte jetzt hier im haus sind herzlich
willkommen wie heute auf jeden fall zu
einem video in dem jude und ich uns
beide einen kurs gekauft sind die kam
nicht viel leichter in erinnerung vorm
supermarkt und ich haben uns auf jeden
fall gestern abend jeder einen kürbis
gekauft den wir schon von einem einsatz
nur von vorne schön von der seite sind
meine ein bisschen platt gedrückt aus
und auch ein bisschen vergammelt oder so
fast dahin braucht da doch ein kühler
video heute hat auf jeden fall wirklich
keine richtigen challenge factor oder
irgendwas wir werden einfach nur bei der
challenge machen jeder kürbis und die
dürfen nach entscheiden welcher besser
aus ich würde allerdings haben glauben
gar nicht mehr lange drum herum ist es
ja halloween deswegen werden wir den
kürbis auch so ein bisschen spooky mäßig
machen
wir haben jeder hier in erding und
werden erst mal so ein gesicht glaube
ich rein mal ich habe bereits gesagt das
noch nie gemacht ich weiß nicht mehr
richtig vorgeht
ich bin nicht zuerst was mal öl essig du
bist hässlich haben wir die leute bisher
sehen und bei uns bei euch auch beim
regnen
wie willst du das denn ausschneiden
krieges apple das ist mein arzt
abgesprochen damit menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
das ist mir nach dem schrauber da wird
werde ich die augen machen ist kein
akkuschrauberrennen der bohrer mir auch
egal ich finde das sieht schöner aus
aber meiner sicht furchteinflößender aus
ist aber auch egal wie der clip ist
jetzt gerade aussieht denn es geht ja
darum wie das nachher aussieht als
erstes sollen jetzt hier oben einen
deckel reinsch nein ich bin wirklich
also ich glaube jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie dumm rum also ich habe noch
nie einen kürbis geschnitzt auch als
kind irgendwie nie irgendwie hatte ich
nie so richtig die begeisterung für
halloween nicht wann immer irgendwie
weihnachten kohler
gerade war fand ich immer gut bietet
allein den deckel wieder aus dann den
deckel haben dann müssen wir dieses
gratis noch kein weg ist da das aussieht
so spinnen dingsbums also wir haben das
früher als in der stadt aachen wird
gemacht dass wir uns verkleidet haben
dann sind bestimmt und eignet sich ja
sogar ein haus zu haus gelaufen so sarah
tätigkeit gegeben ja richtig viele
hoffen die wäsche bekommt dann mal zu
details ich weiß nicht ob es nur bei
mesut aber allgemein auch meine freunde
damals in einer kurzen bereich als der
autobahn oder sogar mir da gar nicht
mehr weiter gemacht aber wir sind
wirklich
wir hatten irgendwie nie so die das
interesse dafür wie weit man karneval
viel unterwegs war das konzert groß
gefeiert wurde aber wir waren jetzt nie
so richtig dass man gesagt hat eekholt
verkleiden und andere haben von haus zu
haus bauen und süßigkeiten damit war
auch die sache ich habe früher als kind
mal mit einem schulkollegen an der
stelle nils weißt du dass hier die
schöne grüße wir haben irgendwie scream
bei ihm gekauft bzw nicht screen sondern
scary movie aber das spielt dieser
stream halt mit mit dieser komischen
mast
und ich hatte danach irgendwie 14 tage
albträume weil die hatte dass der mich
in einer holzfabrik befolgt hat man
hatte eine helle diese maske auch in
seitdem habe ich irgendwie nicht so
richtig halloween gefeiert
ich habe auch einmal scary movie geguckt
als wir sind nur ein ausschnitt soll ich
hatte etwas ältere freundin und dann
haben diejenigen 14 und ich war hinter
glas mit zehn jahren gekoppelt und ich
bin sowieso total paranoid und hat auch
hier eine krasse angst führung haben wir
das geguckt und ich musste nicht so
übernahm denke aber ich bin so schlimm
gute story bei uns leben hier unsere
familie und die haben so zwei hinter die
sind irgendwie alt sind die drei und
sechs oder irgendwie so auf jeden fall
können die halt wenn wir am fenster
stehen können die man bei uns rein guckt
und ich glaube wenn die dass sie gerade
sehen würden
die werden richtig neidisch weil
eigentlich ist ja noch gar nicht so
richtig halloween zeit aber das ist ja
irgendwie so ende oktober also erst in
zwei wochen und die machen das aber
jetzt schon weiß nicht ob diese kürbisse
gesehen im revier hier bei uns in der
nähe und dachte mir einfach jeder
vielleicht muss ich das video habe und
dieser kürbis schnitzen den gemacht und
allgemein mache ich auch letzter zeit
nicht so videos von wenig von der kamera
und lava einfach ein bisschen sondern
halt schon immer eigentlich mit einem
plan und deswegen dass das heutige video
ist dafür vielleicht ganz gut geeignet
du gehst ja irgendwie ein bisschen
professioneller anhalt ist ja todes
anstrengend wenn abend tut schon so wie
ihr könnt ihr einfach mal ein bisschen
mitschreiben in die kommentare wenn wir
hier über irgendwelche themen reden die
beispielsweise scream oder so habt ihr
das auch geguckt handy überhaupt diese
scream maske ich würde ihr euch jetzt
gern einblenden
allerdings will ich das nicht google
weil dann ich locker heute nach wieder
einheit formen bekommen ich hatte heute
nacht schon blöden albtraum jurist
so bestanden raus sie ihren armen auf
meinen rücken gelegt hat und meinte du
kriegst du nicht noch mal drin war
danke schenkt mir das ding aber den
nachweis genannt und sozusagen
das wird sie ab
ich kann das nicht das rezept gebraut
ich kann jetzt an lassen sich auch
irgendwann in zehn jahren schwang jetzt
einfach auch schon mal an zu stützen
ein kürbis ist vollends war noch nicht
so komplett hohl view des kopf will ich
etwas anfangen zu schnitzen
von daher fand ich selbstständig mit der
nase an womit hast die nase schon habt
ihr denn auch an halloween immer euer
haus so voll dekoriert mit so eine
mutter hat das nicht abstellen der
gewählt und zierte eingängen kamera
überrascht wenn jemand klingen rufen wir
die polizei haben halt sogar immer leute
dann geklingelt noch so leute die ich
aus der schule kampf und ich selbst
wusste was gemeint war sehr wichtig mit
kommen oft nicht mehr danke ich bleibe
lieber der hinzu hoffe meine nacht
werden wir doch nicht so zufrieden das
war so das krasseste was er je an
sicherheiten bekommen habt also gab es
ja irgendwie so ein haus wo die man
total spendabel waren oder nicht -
gegangen aber gab es bei euch auch für
haushalte die dann so richtig an die
wand geworfen haben oder an die
haushalte haben die alge wochen das
waren teilweise kindern es gab wirklich
vor doch irgendwie so spaß weil wir dann
eben in der stufe waren oder so die halt
die krumme laufen sondern an die häuser
geworfen haben wo ich mir denke das ist
einfach nicht wir sind von halloween
vollidiot ich hab verkackt
frage kommt von nele punkten bs und zwar
lauft ihr selbst an halloween also jetzt
nicht mehr
ich glaube ich wäre echt ist verrät
nicht gefragt wie man am besten ein
mädchen fragt ob das mit ihren
abschlussball gehen möchte hat nichts
mit halloween zu tun aber vielleicht
haben die an halloween abschluss ich
würde sagen dass du die personen befragt
viele scheitern schon daran dass er sich
gar nicht trocken
wie fragt meine person ich würde sagen
fragt sie hat viele scheitern schon
daran dass sie sich einfach nicht raus
zu fragen und wenn du dich nicht drauf
zu fragen und weiß nicht ob du eine
absage zusage gekommen
das ist ein junge der würde erwarten
dass mädchen films fragt was werden wir
alle halloween dieses jahr machen
also wenn man schon gesagt wir werden
jetzt nicht rumlaufen mit lecker sich
dann die ganze zeit ich glaube wir haben
kein großes programm
vielleicht feiern gehen an halloween
sind immer coole partys verarbeiten
bestimmt nicht ich war schon mal feiern
da habe ich mir so dingen so richtig
mache fast mit dem essen einem auge
alter mein körper ist ziemlich versteckt
hinaus ist lydia fragt was war euer
lieblings kostüme also ja wie bereits
gesagt ich selbst bin ich an halloween
so richtig rumgelaufen allerdings das
was an halloween ii auf jeden fall am
meisten angst bereich hätte wäre halten
scream kostümen gewesen
julia fragt was war die beste
süßigkeiten mal bekommen habt habe ich
mich schon gefragt ob wir mal so richtig
rastende bekommen habt ihr hat manchmal
geld bekommen
es gab alles möglich
die leute hatten diese mix packung
irgendwie find ich ja da war alles
anderen maßen die kassen alles mögliche
oder halt so was gibt es gab es ja auch
für diesen pulli oder harry wurde also
wir hatten auch extra zwar nicht so von
wegen halloween und hatte mich so geht
das nicht frau sie haben trotz oder
süßigkeiten gekauft wenn andere leute
halt irgendwie geklingelt haben einfach
rausnehmen
ich bin quasi fertig also wir hatten
auch mal so einen riesigen süßigkeiten
vor wenn ihnen die andere kinder bei uns
geklingelt haben aber wir hatten halt
nie ja also ich meine schwester genannt
weiter nie so richtig amrum lauf und bin
fertig ja gut wir warten mal bisschen
spät deckel drauf und wir drehen unsere
typischen und um zur kamera im 3
31 juli dass ich wirklich ein bisschen
klüger aus soll du hast ja in der mühe
gegeben deiner 17 meinert finde ich ein
bisschen gruseliger aus wie bereits
gesagt ist das problem gerade dass es
hier oben oder allgemeinen draußen noch
relativ hell ist von daher würde ich
sagen wir bewegen uns normal in meinen
bart unten denn dort ist es ziemlich
dunkel also wir sind jetzt angekommen
hier unten in meinem aufnahme zimmer und
an meinen aufnahmen an grant sind es
halt hier das beste partie haben wir
vorne die kürbisse mal hingestellt wird
sagen wir schieben jetzt jemand die tür
zu und ich mache das nicht aus ich
beschriftete mal eben die kürbisse also
ohm einen korb dass sie damit diese
leuchtet ein
ich glaube der kürbis von unit hier
einfach eine zu dünne dingsbums kommt
christian ahlmann marl blöd ist es
natürlich noch mal eben nicht bei mir
geht es hier relativ weit rein also
nochmal so 23 cm ist es hier noch einen
zentimeter
deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich wenn das
licht aus so sieht es auch so aus dass
es ein weisser ein bisschen mehr
leuchtet und relativ knapp ich finde
beide crews mit meinen wirklich
furchteinflößend deine 12 jeden fall ist
wenn er steht bis heute für halloween
special mehr weniger gefallen hat dann
das bringt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video werden schreibt jetzt warum in die
kommentare an welchen kürbis ihr besser
findet welche den fußwegen dass ich bin
bei dem kohle abonniert zudem einen
kanal unter dem video wenn ihr noch
keinen test ist kostenlos
keine videos mehr und menschen aber
derzeit eher clever kickl auf die glocke
ich hoffe euch das video heute gefallene
stinken
[Musik]